[Music]
Monkeys Jumping on the Bed Daisy was
given just weeks to live that was two
years ago she has Rhett syndrome a rare
genetic disorder and suffers from
life-threatening infections
most of her young life has been spent
going in and out of Hospital Daisy has
defied doctor's predictions but still
requires round-the-clock palliative care
her parents though only get help nine to
five Monday to Friday having to think
about the possibility of your child not
making it through the night is possibly
one of the worst things you're ever
gonna have to face and having to face
that without
the right support is
it's pretty awful really that's night
after night week after week month after
month it sometimes feels unsustainable
the number of District nurses who can
provide palliative care in the community
has dropped by two-thirds in the past 20
years and around 30 percent of those
aren't qualified to give end-of-life
care
I think District nursing is quite
undervalued for the first time we've
seen District nurse numbers drop from to
under 4 000 in the country and that's a
very serious situation if we're going to
provide care in the community
so this is Amber maestram and we spent a
lot of time in here because Amber may
had complex needs she had a hoist and
and this equipment here that she really
needed Jackie knows just how this crisis
in specialist nursing impacts families
for you
last year she lost her seven-year-old
daughter
Amber May was born with kakner 1A a rare
genetic condition she needed
round-the-clock Specialist Care Nursing
that her mother battled for years to
access
I was told very often we are only
looking at ambermaid's Health needs and
I'd say I'm a mum of three I haven't got
the luxury just to look after one child
I need to make sure the whole family is
looked after also I was made to feel
that I was being greedy asking for more
and I was told that if I have more care
then it's taken away from another family
who may need it Emily wants to enjoy
every precious moment she has left with
Daisy but that's really hard when she
doesn't get the support every mother of
a terminally ill child should receive oh
she's Joshy Sky News